of all the deadliest nastiest most
monstrous creatures contained by the SCP
Foundation there is none quite like
scp-682 a mean green perpetual motion
killing machine this Beast runs on Spite
and unnatural strengths fueled by hatred
and an insatiable thirst for violence
with no known way of permanently
destroying the thing
scp-682 is likely to remain in
Foundation custody until the sun burns
out unless of course the research staff
can finally crack the code on killing
the thing once and for all but one
scientist at the SCP Foundation couldn't
help but Wonder did violence really have
to be the answer was the only way to
manage
scp-682's hateful heart to stop it from
beating Dr bright was having his weekly
movie night Join This Time by scp-507
Who Loved a good film whenever he was in
a dimension that happened to have them
he had campaigned for a viewing of the
Avengers but Dr bright insisted on
something a little more heartfelt he
remembered a book that his mother used
to read to him and recalled that it had
been adapted into a movie so in spite of
scp-507 sulking he pressed play on Black
Beauty the story of a wild creature
forming a bond with a determined young
girl the two learning and growing with
each other and embarking on an unlikely
friendship brought tears to his eyes if
she could tame that wild stallion then
why couldn't he a man of infinite
patience and even more infinite time try
and tame a wild beast of his own that
settled it he was going to take a stand
to try something the foundation had
never dared attempt with scp-682 he was
going to become its friend are you out
of your mind Dr gears nearly dropped his
mug of plain black coffee when Dr bright
told them his plan that thing will tear
you limp from limb before you can so
much as say a word then I'll get another
body I'm willing to put in the work Dr
bright Shrugged but as he looked at Dr
Gear's look of deep concern earned he
decided it would be better to ask for
forgiveness than permission at this
point he had to misdirect and fast I got
you look at your face that was a prank
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'd never try
that anyway lots to do bye and he rushed
off to undertake his Grand Vision by
himself when it worked then he could
make the Rounds Around the foundation
site with his I told you so's Dr bright
hadn't grown up on a horse ranch he
hadn't even grown up with many pets he
had no idea where to begin when it came
to animal taming let alone the
domestication of highly intelligent
misanthropic anomalous animals for an
anomalous being perhaps he needed to try
an anomalous method of taming it
suddenly it occurred to him
scp-010 that could work the iron colors
were stored at site 19 in locked boxes
when warned they would allow the where's
every movement to be controlled via a
handheld remote it was perfect he could
get scp-682 to give him a hug a high
five to learn choreographed dance
routines they could perform together the
possibilities were endless but when he
went to access the Lock storage boxes
the guards posted outside the room asked
what he was doing there testing uh it's
all official he said with the guards
insisted they would have to be notified
if any testing had been approved he
tried to argue with them but as soon as
he saw their expressions turn suspicious
he pivoted hard in a safer Direction
just kidding pranked got you good
yeah you gotta stock one of the guards
forced to chuckle you uh stay uh safe
out there not if I see you first Dr
bright responded realizing only later
that his response made no sense damn
adrenaline The Thrill of the scheme was
making him loopy he needed to Center
himself to refocus and figure out what
his next step would be if the caller had
any chance of working on the massive
reptile the foundation probably would
have tried it before and if he tried to
sneak in and steal one of the damn
things someone might see him then his
plan would be over before it even began
besides he reminded himself he was
trying to befriend
scp-682 not just pilot its movements
like some kind of giant remote control
toy if it listened to him it needed to
be because it wanted to because they had
formed a sacred bond between man and
Beast now scp-010 wasn't the answer he
needed to get the opinion of an expert
pure advice from someone who really knew
what they were doing he hopped online
and found exactly what he was looking
for an obedient seminar on training
difficult animals okay it was
specifically a webinar about obedience
training for dogs with behavioral
problems but what was scp-682 if not a
massive reptilian dog with a whole lot
of behavioral problems besides the
webinar was only fifty dollars so really
what could it hurt Dr bride kicked up
his feet poured himself a drink and
tuned into the video seminar once the
credit card payment went through and the
five-hour session was through he would
know exactly what to do to take scp-682
from ketter to cutie well maybe that was
a bit much but stranger things happened
every day after all he was a guy whose
Soul was trapped in a necklace for all
of eternity with a beeping sound the
live video began and Dr bright prepared
to absorb all the wisdom Dr Monique PhD
in animal psychology had to offer he
nodded off a few times but for the most
part he was able to retain some very
valuable tips first go slowly start
working with your dog or giant anomalous
reptile on familiar behaviors or their
favorite thing to do use positive
reinforcement to encourage even the
smallest of successes this will teach
the pet that training is a good thing
tweeze the transition only make one
change at a time next control the
environment during training sessions
take away potential distractions to help
your pet stay focused put away toys they
might be tempted to play with or things
they might try to eat minimize loud
noises and other intrusions such as
passing
avoid punishment as it can increase
anxiety and damage the relationship
built on trust between pet and owner in
the long term punishment can serve to
increase aggression and other negative
behaviors instead use reward-based
training tactics based around things
that pet wants and likes such as treats
petting and play time when the pet does
act out redirect them to a different
Behavior then reward that when doing
reward-based training however it is
important to choose the right rewards if
the rewards aren't appealing or given
frequently enough they will stop evoking
the desired response in the animal every
animal is different so figure out what
yours loves and give them more of that
this particular tip might be hard to
implement for scp-682 Dr bright thought
as he wrote it down what do you give the
anomaly that hates everything still he
would figure it out the final tips of
note were to make training a habit part
of the daily routine made up of short
training sessions throughout the day if
the training failed to produce desired
results a reasonable pet owner should be
willing to bring in help from a trained
expert this is especially true if the
animal is displaying excessive
aggression that one definitely applied
to scp-682 but there was no one more
qualified to handle it than Dr bright
was in his own opinion at least so with
no one else to call he would have to
tackle the Monumental undertaking
himself Dr Monique concluded her seminar
by asking each attendee about their
respective pets Dr Bryant had to stretch
the truth just a little bit responding
only a big one when asked about his
dog's breed and describing its behavior
problems as aggression and biting while
troubled animals often just need a
little extra love and patience like I
said ask for help if you need it good
luck doctor she said giving him a wave
before he signed out of the meeting so
armed with a can-do attitude an open
heart a spray bottle filled with
hydrochloric acid just in case some toys
and as much much sliced deli turkey as
the local grocery store would sell him
Dr bright prepared to sneak into
scp-682's containment cell he timed it
perfectly waiting for the shift change
so he could slip in unnoticed while the
guards were swapping out using moves he
learned from watching dozens of heist
movies he maneuvered around the security
cameras staying out of sight and let
himself into the high security
containment chamber Dr Monique said to
remove all distractions while training a
pet and the Acid Bath that scp-682 was
submerged in was a pretty massive
distraction how was Dr bright supposed
to teach it anything if the creature's
attention was on the constant corrosion
of its flesh muscle and bone good thing
he paid attention during scp-682's
official testing and knew how to drain
the acid out of the room as
scp-682's body began to rebuild itself
it turned to look at Dr bright eyes
fixed on him it spoke in a voice
dripping with pure disdain why did you
do that
hey buddy Dr bright ignored the question
speaking in a soft higher pitched voice
that Dr Monique recommended for soothing
troubled dogs want a treat he held out a
pack of sliced turkey not waiting for an
answer he tossed the food toward the
reptile and it landed just in front of
the creature's mouth with a soft thud
after a moment of careful study of
making sure this was not some sort of
trick
scp-682 opened its mouth and swallowed
the turkey in one goal more it said
opening its mouth wide exposing its rows
and rows of sharp tees wait a second you
can have more but first sit Dr bright
held up his hand to teach the command
the creature repeated incredulous sit Dr
bright repeated patiently
scp-682 responded with a swipe of its
tail that knocked Dr Wright into the
wall breaking several of his ribs
to write reflexively reached for the
spray bottle squirting some acid onto
the creature's scales it recoiled and Dr
bright became aware of what he was doing
he was using punishment when he should
have been using positive reinforcement
he dropped the spray bottle kicking it
off to the side I'm so sorry buddy that
wasn't nice
I shouldn't have
scp-682 wouldn't even look at him here
you want this catch he held up a large
ball tossing it towards the creature it
bounced off the beast's nose uselessly
disgusting 682 growled you're right that
was disgusting I forgot everything I
learned I let my ego get in the way
listen I promise I'll never do it again
he tossed more turkey towards the
creature and as a date he gently patted
its broad scaly side I know you don't
like my colleagues here I get it why
would you they're always hurting you
trying to control you I know what that's
like we've got a lot in common you know
we've both been through so much pain we
both can't die even if we wanted to if
you let me I could be a friend to you
scp-682 was silent for a moment as it
stared into Dr Bright's eyes considering
his words then it's spoke you are Dr
bright held his breath waiting to hear
what came next
disgusting
scp-682 roared the last thing Dr bright
saw was the monster's Jaws clamping down
around his head and then everything went
black Dr Wright woke up in his offices
with that stiff new body feeling he had
become accustomed to there was a note
waiting for him on his desk on the o5
council's letterhead it read Dr bright I
hope you understand the gravity of what
you did today your careless actions
caused a containment breach of scp-682
that resulted in over a dozen casualties
be thankful you were given a new body at
all as it was briefly debated whether or
not you deserved one but you are too
valuable to the foundation to keep
Locked In The Box remember that do not
interfere with scp-682 again or there
will be dire consequences additionally
as you're viewing of Black Beauty has
been attributed to this incident all
future film viewings must be subject to
formal approval until you can prove that
this is no longer necessary now sit in
your office and think about what you've
done a 05-1 Dr bright slumped over his
desk feeling sorry for himself suddenly
he heard a familiar cooing sound coming
from the doorway he turned and saw the
Tickle Monster here to visit him and
cheer him up it oozed over to his desk
wanting for him to pet it as he patted
its slimy surface he smiled to himself
no matter how many mistakes he made how
much of a screw-up he might feel like
sometimes at least he knew scp-9999
would always be happy to see him forget
horses dogs and especially scp-682 man's
best friend was right here now go and
check out scp-963 what would you do if
you were immortal like Dr Jack Bright
and could Dr Jack Wright Escape Silent
Hill for more Jack Bright Adventures if
you could even call it that